So, breaktime is over; now, you know about "Break."
You know about "while" loops;
you know about "if" to make decisions;
you know everything you need
to finish the goal of today's unit,
which is to write the code for extracting all of the URLs
from a web page.
First, let's remember what we were doing before:
we had the code that kept repeating
to get one link after another.
So, we had code like this: we had finding the "start_link"--
and we assumed, before entering this code,
that "page" has the contents of some web page.
We would search for the start of a link;
then we would find the "start_quote,"
again using "find,"
but this time passing in the start of the tag
and searching for the double quote.
Then, we would find the "end_quote."
And then we would extract the URL using the string selection--
selecting from "page,"
from the "start_quote" to the "end_quote."
Then, we would print out the URL,
and this was what we needed to do for one URL.
We would continue by advancing the "page"
to go from where we found the "end_quote" to the end;
and then we would do all the same thing again to find the next URL.
And we'd keep doing this code, over and over again,
finding as many URLs as there were on the page.
So, here's the code, shrunken down so we have some more space.
What we want to do is extract into a procedure,
this part [indicating the first four lines after "page" is defined];
and then we want to make it so we can keep going.
We've seen "while" loops give us a way to keep going;
so, we'll end up writing a "while" loop that keeps looking for links
till we reach the end of the page.
So, the first thing we're going to talk about is
how we extracted this procedure,
and we're going to need to make a few changes to it,
to make it work well in our "while" loop.
We defined a procedure, "get_next_target"--
that takes the page as an input--
and essentially had exactly the code we have here--
except for, at the end, it would return both the URL
and the value of "end_quote."
And we had a quiz earlier
where you determined that what "get_next_target" should do
is return both the URL and the "end_quote"--
that is the position where the end of the quote was found.
So, we needed this procedure to return two values
because we need to know both the URL, as a string,
and where to continue looking for the next target.
We haven't yet used a procedure that reutrns two things,
but it's actually quite convenient
and simple to do this.
We can do this by just having two values
on the left side of an assignment statement
This works in general; so we can do--
instead of our simple assignment rule,
where we had a name, followed by an equal,
followed by an expression,
and that would assign the value of the expression to "name"--
we can have multiple names on the left side,
and multiple expressions on the right side.
So, we can do multiple assignment,
where we have any number of names,
separated by commas, an equal sign,
and then any number of expressions,
also separated by commas.
As long as the number of names and the number of expressions match,
what happens is the value of the first expression is assigned to the first name--
so this name [indicating ]
will now refer to whatever this value was-- [indicating ]
the value of the second expression is assigned to the second name.
As an example, if we had "a, b = 1, 2",
this would assign to "a" the value "1,"
and to "b" the value "2."
In order to get the two values returned by this procedure,
what we need is to have two variables on the left side
and the procedure call on the right.
The syntax we'll use is just the URL [url]--
we'll use that as the variable to hold the URL;
and "endpos"--
we'll use that as the variable to hold the end position;
and, then, on the right side, we have "get_next_target"
passing in "page."
Since this returns two values, it's like listing two expressions:
the first value returned will be assigned to "url,"
the second value returned will be assigned to "endpos."
Being able to have multiple variables
on the left side of an assignment is very useful.
Let's have a quiz to see an example of "why."